mr. chocolate whenever I get mentally
overwhelmed I shut down completely how
do I counter that well the first thing
and the first good step that you've
already made is you've identified this
as an issue you recognize the fact that
you shut down that's step number one in
solving your problem is identifying your
problem so excellent work there the next
step is actually pretty easy as well
you've identified the fact that you shut
down the next step that you're going to
do is not shut down not mentally shut
down that's what you want to do if you
start to shut down then you feel
yourself freezing up and say I'm not
going to shut down right now I'm going
to attack this issue now the reason that
you're getting overwhelmed most likely
is because there's a lot of different
things flying at you at the same time
and they're all happening at once and
it's problematic for you we have a very
simple solution for that it's prioritize
and execute so what is the biggest
problem that you've got going on let's
identify what that biggest problem is
then let's attack that problem and get
it solved once we got that one solved we
can move on to the next one which we get
to here take care of that one we can
move on to the X when we go right on
down the line that's that's what we do
that's very simple you know that you're
gonna get overwhelmed first of all tell
yourself you're not gonna be overwhelmed
then you actually don't get overwhelmed
and how do you not get overwhelmed
you're prioritizing execute if you start
feeling yourself getting overwhelmed do
what I did to the platoon commander that
I had that was getting all freaked out
during during HMMWV I addressed
immediate action drills where you're
patrolling through the desert and we
have little electrical targets that pop
up and then you everyone starts shooting
at the targets and this guy was locking
up and not making decisions even though
he's the leader mm-hmm and this is the
one where I took a magic marker and I
wrote him with a sharpie right in front
of his face on the Humvee window I said
next time the shooting starts here's
what I want you would want you to number
one relax number two look around
number three make a call it's real easy
so step number one when you're getting
overwhelmed
hmm relax breathe take a step back just
take a step back the red flags start
going off in your head and you're
realizing that you're getting
overwhelmed and you're gonna get
yourself down no just take a step back
relax and then prioritize and execute
pretty simple like a call yeah